what's happened to reject nation I'm
Greg Alba Donald Humphrey John and I are
gonna go watch this trailer we're gonna
go and watch it watches trains Netflix
trailer that's called not the Apostles
star Robert Duvall its apostle starring
Dan Stevens you don't want to get those
confused like room in the room or
predator and the predator you know for
predators or apostles possible we're
gonna get one we gonna get apostles okay
so this is on Netflix I wanted to
mention that Oh Brad our patreon we do
plenty of TV show reactions I myself
cover attack on Titan made it to season
to Gotham on season 1 right now John
covers Full Metal Alchemist Brotherhood
he covers Riverdale as well he's also on
season 2 of that together we cover my
hero academia and supernatural we stream
most of them from Netflix so it's not be
appropriate to shout it out we also do
weekly Q&A throughout the weeks there so
go check out our patreon when you get
this is from Gareth Evans who did
Godzilla and rogue wasn't leave it there
and everyone thinks oh actually I think
we'll get a good 50 50 people like no
way the other people like ah actually
it's Edward a different first name last
name
we're being sarcastic and making this
commentary now everyone is still gonna
be like which it is I actually know the
difference between those two people's ah
ha ha they're both white they're both
white I ain't no one did in Indonesian
successful ones ones Welsh and the other
ones like is he British I don't know
anyway this one's Welsh
Thomas Oh sister
she's gone most people say blasphemers
cult a disease-resistant whatever is a
suitable world in which each working day
we this island it's our paradise we have
an intruder on island we have to find
him
[Music]
you are you whoa oh come to you in
sheep's clothing but inwardly
[Music]
Wow oh my gosh
[Music]
[Music]
soft [ __ ] right there
oh that's even cooler than the spinning
cross right there just the dropping the
cross oh man looks quite evil looks like
a perfect combination of the raid and
VHS to a little bit just for that one
split moment of action look I've been
watching a lot of religious horror
lately yeah cult act big part of my life
lately it's about time we join a real
cult yeah Scientology or Catholic Church
down the street from us as well this is
called apostle and his name is Thomas
and he's the outsider of this you know
story I'm kind of confused why he's
there though why he's still there he's
out to find his sister established by
the beginning of his trailer is one of
them his sister and she's sticking
around this cult and is refusing to
leave and he's trying to get her out or
is she like dead looking for her it was
unclear a little bit confused by the
plotline of why he's sticking around nut
sure yeah for sure he's the only person
in the IMDB who has a last name so
that's no yeah I wasn't really clear on
that but I do just think that the the
tone and the vibe I love kind of
paranoid religious cult type movies this
is one of those trailers that kind of
bums me out that this won't play on a
bunch of screens because it does look
like a very visual movie well I don't
know if you heard the news lately John
but IMAX is trying to make an agreement
with streaming services such as Amazon
and Netflix to release their original
movies on IMAX you know time they want
to watch this on your small screen at
home come see it on the biggest possible
that's a good few days only
I like the
Plan B great idea the fact that it's on
Netflix and Gareth Evans is a pretty
solid track record for me it's kind of
fitting to say from the director of the
raid franchise because the raid one not
so much but I remember watching the raid
too and being scared this is kind of
scary
he's the situation he's constantly in so
there are times we were on edge and
worried for sometimes like a violent
imagery or a plot turn oh yeah we can be
totally harrowing just in another way
and yeah this definitely looks like a
harrowing experience I don't imagine
you'll hold back on the violence either
from what I know about the work of
Gareth Evans the right one right Edwards
is Godzilla yeah I guess my question
that usually comes up with these
religious cult horror films is is it
supernatural or is it all psychological
that's what I was curious because
there's at least that one shot where
Michael Sheen's walking up with that
straight razor and there's something
like reaching a sickly arm out and I was
like this is some kind of yeah witch
thing or demon Hellspawn creature or is
it just you know a all-too-human victim
of some kind well it seems to be from
you know the darker side of Christianity
the yeah the Catholic side I'm assuming
that's upon well we're talking about
like God is suffering God is all this
some like yeah it does a god I grew up
with sounds related I mean there are
also much more extreme sects of
Christianity too so I don't I don't
think this is dealing with Catholicism
or anything you know it's probably a bit
more specific but it definitely took me
back to those puritanical kind of
elements and it reminded me a lot of
like a witch movie just in the burning
crosses and the torture and all these
people in bonnets and stuff standing
around to remind me of like a witch
trials movie but just about a religious
cult instead I'm imagining that it's
more than a psychological territory like
there's there's one character I'm
actually really gravitated towards in
this trailer it's the one who's all
bloodied up with a bag over his head who
seems to be torturing people or
capturing them he just seems like
someone who they've I don't know if he's
the same guy who they like you know when
they had that upside down shot of the
burning and then they put like what's I
call when they burn on brand yeah with a
brand him I don't know if that's
same guy as kind of what the imagery
here let me to believe he looks like the
doof warrior from Mad Max it seems like
he's been pushed to this edge of being
this servant for this cult yeah just the
awful doer of nasty deeds yeah yeah
whatever any of the pious folk don't
want to do to get their hands dirty that
guy probably has to do and Dan Stevens
is gonna show up and kick a lot of
religious ass and a and I mean Dan
Stevens is at least in in what I've seen
him in he always leaves a good
impression on me I think he's got a lot
of chops as an actor and this looks like
a movie where you could enjoy those
chops and also get to eat your cake too
because of all the weird whacked-out
stuff in the second half of the trailer
you know I don't think this will be a
movie that's obscenely fast paced and
like always getting crazy and stuff but
it seems like you know a nice
performance movie yeah and Michael Sheen
looks really awesome too man I like when
that guy's a bad guy like the Twilight
franchise is especially like that this
is just a prequel the only one I could
think become a vampire at the end and
then he's gonna you know move out to
Rome and [ __ ] it wouldn't be much of a
stretch no and then Dan Stevens is gonna
fall under some kind of curse and become
the Beast and there you go oh wow yeah
you brought this whole movie down yeah
man it's just an elaborate dual prequel
well guys you know who's a good apostle
of this channel a man named Joe Annie I
think that's how you say his name Joanne
with a why I think I actually asked him
specifically how to say it well I
thought it was Joanie
hey said right here this is a brand name
like Joe Annie I got all right joining
Joe Annie
Joe any is 15 years old so we're gonna
make all the perverted comments
twenty-eight-year-old should not make to
a fifteen-year-old right now starting
with how do we play this inappropriate
but not that inappropriate no Joe Annie
is from London and he actually just
traveled all throughout America much
from California to San Fran Utah to
Grand Canyon to Bryce Canyon or Bryce
Canyon is Arizona Nevada are you smart
I'm in Las Vegas and much
this guy is 15 and has already done more
traveling than myself and John included
so thanks for rubbing it in our face
Johnny Johnny do you want a man you want
a man but in all seriousness I've had
some conversations with the kid and he's
a good kid he's got a bright future kid
I can't wait till you're 18 man because
right now he has a channel you all
should subscribe to because if we help
him get to at least 10,000 followers by
the time he turns 18 the latest
yeah plus you know probably make a
little scratch for that tuition take off
some of that load there yes and that you
cannot leave me others off it's about
women it's always about you live the
life with the women party it up and then
you're a deadbeat after college is you
didn't pay attention in school that's
how that's your future son if you stick
at it and keep posting video yeah so go
subscribe to the Joannie channel don't
subscribe little way yeah it's reverse
psychology see cuz like once you tell
somebody not to look this like well I
have to look every time I tell people to
unsubscribe we lose a thousand
subscribers
daddy thanks for being part of the
patreon page you're a beautiful son of a
B I can tell by this Mandy look in
profile photo you have yourself dude
much love to you guys what do you think
of this movie apostle this look better
than the Apostle who is your favorite
apostle out of the Bible put it in the
comments below
mine is Paul which one you're gonna have
to tune in to find out you can subscribe
to the reject nation click that
notification bell to get notified every
time one of our vids is up and hey you
could check us on patreon we got TV show
reactions q and A's and some music video
coverage would love to have me become a
patron eject to our patron page today
yeah